[Music]
i'm remiss i must i should have done
this right when you came out but i
didn't congratulations you just got
engaged and i think that's fantastic
[Applause]
tell us
it was wonderful tell us what was the
what was the experience like of getting
engaged
it was a shocker i was very surprised
we've been together for five years
almost five years and he managed to
surprise me which is wonderful and um
but also kind of weird at the same time
because
i went in i blacked out
i did black out and he came it all
happened he was talking to me and i saw
a box and it just went
black
so i don't know what happened he roofied
you is what he did he drugged me
are you seriously blacked out i know it
went well because we're planning a
wedding so i know that i must have said
all the right things well when you came
to or was he like you said yes yeah
you said you're gonna do it and you're
gonna do it yeah and it's gonna be like
this
what are you do you are you being
serious that you blacked out or you just
got so excited that you kind of yeah it
was just such a surreal moment i mean
that i mean it you know it happens and
you when especially when you don't you
don't know that it's gonna happen it
just i don't know it took my breath away
and i was very uh stunned and shocked
and excited is your family excited are
they gonna is your mom getting into it
because moms love to get involved my mom
is now like i told you last time i was
here she got threw up in a yoga class
which was sad i'm sorry i didn't mention
that again it was classic television
[Laughter]
and um but now she's like okay that's it
i'm really i'm gonna get into serious
shape for this wedding and i'm gonna
look great so she's doing zumba so i
call her and i said so are you excited
for zumba tonight it's just it's a latin
yeah
i don't know what zumba is because
it's in the news a lot now yeah there's
like people are latin
inspired fitness dance classes but she
goes she goes i'm going to do it half
speed because i don't want to be sore
tomorrow
i go but what do you mean half speed how
do you do a latin dance it's like if you
kick out this way she's going to go no
so she's doing she's doing zumba and
she's yeah she's kind of doing it half
speed i like when you're doing it uh
it's but it's like a sexy kind of dance
it is it's like you know kicks and
swirls and spins and you know and men i
wonder how men do it i have not been do
men go to zumba classes or do they only
go
to look at women you know that one in
maine yes where the prostitute was was
teaching
i think men were going to that one yeah
[Laughter]
suspiciously
i'm not here to dance you know why i'm
here
i think i'm going to try that zumba yeah
of course they're all in names
but it's not forbidden
now i want to try it
we have a clip here from happy endings
uh and congratulations on the show
people really love it you guys are
having terrific success anything we need
to know for this clip um yeah well dave
and i um my ex-fiance on the show are
back together and this is us sort of
explaining to the rest of the gang that
we're uh
we're together now let's take a look
well big news out of this corner these
two are going to meet with a real estate
agent and look at apartments today stop
before you start just stop right in your
tracks we know what you're thinking okay
then we're moving too fast but we can't
go backwards we just can't yeah jane
you're probably like
bad idea i'm gonna do my kegel exercises
and penny you're probably like omg this
is so not amazing yeah and max is all
like you guys are so stupid and so not
fierce
and then brad is like oh hell no you two
white isn't moving in together jive ass
turkeys don't even sound like that
wait
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sake and you have a you have a parrot on
the show i do have a parrot and this
parrot is
he's racist and homophobic
the only the only heart i love that idea
while he is a parrot that's the way they
are yeah
yeah his only hobby is racism so it's
tough you know to get him interested in
another actually when i heard that idea
i thought it's a very funny idea a
racist homophobic character who
embarrasses everything yeah we do a lot
of things together too on the show which
is a lot of fun we did like
i brought a picture of us as thumb and
louise and we just do a lot of fun
things we have that i think you guys
dressed up as thelma and louise on the
show
oh